[MUSIC PLAYING]
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Hello.
I'm Dustin Kirkland
here a KubeCon.
And I'm joined by Lakshmi
Sharma, Director of Product
Management at Google.
Her team works on some
of the hardest network
problems at Google.
Lakshmi, can you
tell us a little bit
about what it takes to
think about networking
at tremendous scale inside
of GCP and with Kubernetes?
LAKSHMI SHARMA: Sure.
So a lot of work that we do
in networking-- to be honest,
this has been done
over 10, 12 years.
We all know that
Kubernetes really
started from the intra
search and management
right inside Google's
data center like bulk.
And so most of the networking
pieces that we have,
they really run all those
applications at scale,
whether we talk about global
load balancer, internal load
balancers, and then doing that
at the geographical scales
at which we support
already 4 billion users,
4 billion containers every week.
So that's a kind
of problem we have,
to be honest, solve at the
connectivity level, DDoS
level, and all of that, but
now, taking that problem
and trying to solve the problem
for our enterprise customers
so that they can get
that kind of scale
for business just like
we at Google have solved.
So that's a problem we are
solving at this point--
how do we enable our
enterprise customers
to be able to manage
their business
and focus there and by
offering manage GKE--
manage GKE networking?
And recently, we just did an
alpha launch for something
called [? NEG, ?] network and
[? growing ?] groups and things
like that.
And all these offerings are
going to enable our enterprises
to get managed services.
And they can get a
seamless networking
from Google and BNGKEGCP.
So I'm biased.
I will talk about
Google networking so
what we have done.
We are taking GKE ingress
to a very high scale
using Google and
Google Store balancers
and integrating them
into GKE ingress.
That will give you the
large scale of networking
and security, SSL
proxies, all that you
need to secure your perimeter.
And then through the same GKE
ingress, same load balancers,
you can get the native load
balances for containers.
If you still want to
continue to use NGNX,
you can use, if you
want to still continue
to use your choice
of load balancers.
But if you want the
scale of the entire globe
and then being able to use
the Edge and the services
that we have, GKE ingress
with our load balancers.
Those are the problems we solve.
And we want enterprises to
be free of those problems.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: So
you've talked a lot
about ingress and egress here.
Can you tie this back to Istio
and some of the networking
challenges that you and
your team are solving
and how that fits in
with the Istio project?
LAKSHMI SHARMA: Sure.
So Istio, known as Service
Mesh, and the control
plane for different
kinds of proxies,
let's talk about ingress,
middle, and the side car proxy.
And sitting either with
something like Envoy
or- in case of
Google, integrated
with Google's load balancers.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
And can you tell me
a little bit about
what you're hearing
from enterprise customers in
terms of multi-cloud demands
on networking?
LAKSHMI SHARMA: So I'll
talk about two categories
of customers.
So one is just the
cloud native customers.
Most of our initial
customers were really
cloud native customers.
And then various
other cloud providers,
they had initially
customers onboarded,
which were traditional
enterprise ID customers.
So I'll pick both
kinds of customers.
So enterprise ID
customers, they are
hybrid from the perspective of
on prem and some public cloud,
or they may have some
instances of private cloud.
So they're hybrid that way.
And cloud native companies,
relatively newer companies,
gaming companies--
Pokemon being one of them.
So those companies, they
were just born and brought up
in cloud.
So then those other
companies, which
we have most of
experiences with,
so even those
companies, in order
to get some data locality, those
kinds of rules and regulations,
we see them also going to some
multi-cloud kind of scenarios
just primarily for
the data scenarios.
But anytime you move
data, you end up
being in the networking
space as well.
So that's we are seeing
traditional IT companies.
They going on prem, off prem.
And then they want a choice
of another public cloud.
But for cloud native
companies, they
started with one cloud
vendor, like let's say GCP.
And we also see them going to
other cloud providers because
of some compliance reasons
or data localities.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
And what would you
say the hardest
problem is that we're
working on right now
from a Google perspective
on networking in the
cloud native space?
LAKSHMI SHARMA: So
hardest problem,
nothing is hard for Google.
We are really smart and genius.
[LAUGHS]
So I'd say from a
privatization perspective
and what do we want to
do in an upcoming year.
So we have two cloud
providers, very famous ones.
So they have a huge base of
large enterprise customers.
And we are really good with
cloud native companies.
So looking at sudden
verticals and I'd
say retail, gaming,
financials, and looking
at those problems,
which we know already
that we can solve,
especially in terms
of low latency, high
bandwidth, anywhere,
we know that we are
really good at it.
But how do we
bundle that together
and start offering them as a
networking secure services,
which means integrating with
our IAM, giving our visibility
and monitoring all the
way to stack drivers
and also giving
one platform APIs.
So to be honest,
really networking
which crosses the
horizontal domain,
how do you package that
together, and really
start bringing large
enterprises together,
and then show them
what our value add is?
Because networking seems
easy and that's what we want,
but hard to explain.
So being able to explain them
so they can visualize that,
I guess that's
where the problem.
Simple problem to solve.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Indeed.
Thank you for your
time, Lakshmi.
LAKSHMI SHARMA: Thank you.